can't imagine you were ever in any way
ugly Salma but I know that you did have
some insecurities about your physical
appearance didn't you when you were
younger I were talking about my breasts
now yes we are talking about your
breasts yes because I was the youngest
in in my class all the girls started
getting them and I wasn't getting
anything and I was really scared what
did you do
okay we went on a road trip with my
parents and we went to this church that
had a saint that was supposed to do a
lot of Miracles
because everybody was like older and I
was like the skinny tomboy yes and so
when we went back to the car I said oh I
forgot something I went back in the
church put my hands in the holy water
and went please Jesus
[Applause]